all right let's get into this game hey
chair with money so in this game I'm
supposed to save Donald Trump from dying
oh oh boy am I trying hard to save him
please from I am I am trying really hard
to save you Trump I'm coming for you
baby
ah no oh oh he's up there rebooting
they're having a great time and the
world is a better place
oh I can push oh come on
push push push
Oh
[Music]
did it work are they making out they're
making up I do ship Trump and Putin
don't get me wrong but this must be
stopped
okay I get it I got it I do this I do
this I do this I do this and then I do
this that's it it's not that [ __ ]
hard it's not that [ __ ] hard look at
this
[Music]
there we go yes [ __ ] you now I joined
the party yeah I'm driving the car now
Russia I'm driving the [ __ ] car now
yeah you like this yeah you like this
mr. Putin oh yeah that's what you [ __ ]
war that's what you're [ __ ] wrong
okay next level oh they got chairs
but guess what I got [ __ ] courage
never mind hey I'm coming for you trim
I'm coming to save you crab or not okay
cue the epic music
I thought that yes yes yes yes
just you [ __ ] with my man is that what
it is if you curveball you can make
yourself like super high alright let's
just do that
[Applause]
[Music]
Walker
don't look down to keep going
[Music]
[Applause]
now I know what the 14 year olds playing
God feel I am the 14 year olds playing
hi oh the satisfaction of that [ __ ]
[ __ ] and the slow-mo
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] touch a trench
enter two children
yes get up get up and save Trump get up
get up get what the [ __ ] is oh my god
what the [ __ ] is this okay we just gotta
hit him in the right angle
[Music]
[ __ ] come on Trump oh [ __ ]
all right this one should be easy [ __ ]
[ __ ] there it is
pepper pepper pepper
but oh my god a mist
it's been an honor and privilege to
serve by your country now there's just
one thing I would like to do thank you
are these tampons these are giant
tampons who made this game please
tampons be good to me like I've been
good to you thank you and for uh uh I
got his hair this is just part it's part
of the contract it was all part of the
contract saved goddamn tampons all right
fine I know what fine fine fine I feel
like this is a weird nightmare that I'm
reliving how much get up there
[Music]
oh my god oh my god Trump
oh yeah
[Music]
she was spinning
why am I still playing this game at this
point there's really no reason for it
besides that I love to play this game
there's no political [ __ ] [ __ ]
there's no political agenda I swear it's
[ __ ] stupid god I mean come on come
on come on come on come on come on come
on last [ __ ] try
[Applause]
[Music]
why am I playing this game it comes a
time in everyone's life where you ask
yourself why and I think the Y has
turned into it
can I please die I'm just chillin in
Cedar Rapids you made three speeches for
Goldman Sachs we were paid $675,000 for
three speeches was that a mistake and
was that a bed which she was paid six
hundred thousand for a speech oh I'll
give you a speech oh oh oh this is
fueling me this is fueling me to play
this game [ __ ] it crashed a great man
once said it's will happen this is it
won't happen it will happen I'm telling
you it will it will it will happen I
won't [ __ ] stick god damn it
[ __ ] here we go here we go this
is like
when Neil went to save Trinity
[Music]
why do I come every time that was the
end of the chapter
ah where the [ __ ] am I now
[Music]
yay
it's arias [ __ ] green you're not even
Trump what are you [ __ ] jacksepticeye
what the [ __ ] is that why is it green
I'm not saving jack [ __ ] that fairness
fairness fairness Curtis he's alive he's
alive
I saved jacksepticeye why is he
jacksepticeye I don't understand I'm
still not over it did I beat the [ __ ]
game yet it has to end here please end
here the [ __ ] happened what the [ __ ]
what the what the [ __ ] happened what the
[ __ ] have you got a duty to do
everything is going smooth so far
everything is going fantastic oh no no
no
why is he silvery why is he naked that's
why that's [ __ ] wine there it is just
keep frontf let him front-flip for
America this is why you should vote
bianna from be honest magazine
[ __ ] the other crowd is going
crazy front flip your way to victory
come on
Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
Bam Papa oh that's [ __ ] ass dude
you're [ __ ] muscular now dude what oh
oh oh oh oh that smells very good mr.
president why am I always too far no no
there it is America I did it please tell
me I did it please tell me I did it I
don't wanna play anymore I don't wanna
play anymore I don't wanna play anymore
I don't wanna play anyone I did it I did
it I didn't thirty what
[Music]
the world is a better place